по-перше я дякую всім співавторам цієї
постанови і Хочу зазначити про велику
участі І підготовці Івана
климпоштинцадзе Олексія Гончаренка і
сказати що такі речі мають об'єднати
український парламент адже прийняття
цієї заяви по суті відкриє шлях для
Міністерства закордонних справ України
розірвати дипломатичні взаємини з іраном
сьогодні в світі сформована терористична
вісь зла Російська Федерація і ці країни
які безпосередньо причетні до злочинів
проти Мирного українського народу це
Білорусь яка дала на жаль своїй
території для бомбардування України і
Іран з дронівших-хідів якої щодня На
жаль в різних регіонах України вбивають
українських мирних громадян руйнують
критичну інфраструктуру і житло і тому
для нас Шановні колеги дуже важливо в
цій постанові не тільки визнати цей а й
закликати міжнародну спільноту зробити
все можливо щоби прослідити ланцюжок цих
поставок до Ірану комплектаючих і
можливих товарів подвійного використання
які потім формують цю вбивчу зброю
звернутися до наших партнерів перервати
всі ці ланцюжки так само дуже важливо що
в цій заяві ми згадуємо трагедію збитого
українського літака літака мау і
Закликаємо Іран визнати свою причетність
до цього теракту також дуже важливо що
саме Україна має розпочати внести
санкції проти фізичних і юридичних осіб
причетних до використання і виготовлення
цих Дронів і продажу їх Російській
Федерації Україна має бути першою і
потім закликати весь світ так само
включити пекельні санкції проти Ірану
причетного до
вбиття мирного населення України і кож
економічною і юридичної особи
безпосередньо причетною до виготовлення
і